[Musique]
la balance board
m
[Musique]
et
petit week-end en famille où on profite
effectivement d'un moment pour fêter les
50 ans de mariage de la marraine de
justin ma compagne on en famille avec
mon fiston elliot on parle de techno on
parle de plein plein de choses et puis
on va faire plaisir aussi pour l'instant
il fait beau je crois que demain ils
annoncent un temps dégueulasse
poursuite d'un petit week end en famille
pour pouvoir parler effectivement du
choix à faire aujourd'hui entre samsung
d'un côté et son fameux et suites et de
l'autre côté apple et son iphone 8 qui
va arriver aussi d'ici quelques temps
parce qu'arrêter c'est pas juste une
question de savoir quel smartphone on va
choisir mais vraiment dans quel univers
on va aller parce que quand tu as choisi
un téléphone quand tu as choisi une télé
connectée quand tu as choisi un système
connecté parce qu'en réalité c'est bien
ça dont on parle c'est d'un système
global
une fois que tu as mis le pied dedans
c'est compliqué partir sur un autre
système parce que ça représente beaucoup
d'investissements c'est très cher et
puis une fois que tu as un appareil qui
est connecté avec tous tes données
dedans c'est compliqué de revenir en
arrière et la réelle question les la
question n'est pas tant de choisir le
dernier téléphone à la mode mais
vraiment de savoir dans quel système on
va mettre les pieds et dans quel système
on soit travail parce que c'est vraiment
là que vous reçu les technologies du
futur
[Musique]
on se rendait compte aujourd'hui on
choisit un système global en a des
montres connectés on est sur des
tablettes qui sont plus proches des
ordinateurs avec des petits claviers
campréal smartphone on peut pas appeler
avec on voit bien tous les objets ont
une relation entre une vraie relation
entre eux et que aujourd'hui voilà il
faut choisir vers quoi on va on sait
même que steve jobs de quelques temps
d'un projet avec nike à la voiture du
futur donc peut-être qui aura pas de
voiture du futur
mais en tout cas il y aura probablement
un os développé soit par google soit par
apple probablement pour des voitures au
risque d'y arriver dans les années qui
viennent
nos maisons sont de plus en plus
connectés les ampoules connecter les
télés connectées les frigos connectés on
va avec les applications de santé aussi
plus vert plus de connexions bientôt nos
données de santé seront transmises
directement nos médecins les gens qui
sont sous surveillance cardiaque qui ont
des problèmes de tension artérielle
énormément tous comme ça on pourra tout
transmettre grâce à des bracelets grâce
à des mondes connectés
donc on voit bien pour avoir plus de
connectivité donc la réalité aujourd'hui
est la vraie question
elle se pose en savoir vers quel
environnement tu vas quelle est la
technologie qui séduit le plus
et puis quelle il sait qu a pris plus
d'avancé par rapport aux autres et qui
correspond le mieux à toi attabi tous
les jours et à tes choix de vie parce
que si on devait retenir qu'une seule
chose de la keynote de samsung c'est ça
toujours plus de connectivité pour notre
service et c'est ça le réel intérêt il
réalise ovation je te le dis les
applications santé
les applications de maison d'ailleurs
apple fait tourner une pub pour les
applications maison tu vois vraiment que
c'est vers ça que se dessine la nouvelle
technologie tu dois aussi avec samsung
d'aix tu vois très bien qu'en réalité
ton téléphone se pose sur un boîtier et
devient sur un moniteur un ordinateur de
bureau et tu vois qu'en réalité tout ce
mélange
aujourd'hui les gens disent et très cher
de mettre 700 800 900 euros 1000 euros
pour un téléphone mais on est plus sur
un téléphone on est sur un assistant de
vie et c'est là-dessus aujourd'hui que
le que le que le progress des signes que
la technologie dessine tâche est plus un
smartphone tâche est un assistant de vie
et tu le vois bien un bracelet connectés
qui est liée directement à un smartphone
qui va être lié probablement un toubib
demain qui va être permettre de
commander sa maison à distance
comment dit-on chauffage comme on
l'était store allumé la télé mettre la
musique
surveillez voir ce que font tes gosses
regarder la télé écouter la radio
écouter des podcasts regarder youtube
tout ça c'est connecter directement sur
ton smartphone kin et je pense même que
l'appellation smartphones et plus bonne
il faudrait trouver un autre terme un
peu hybride parce qu'on est plus sûr du
smartphone on est vraiment sur des
technologies qui deviennent des vrais
assistant de vie et à mon avis c'est un
il va falloir trouver un thème pour
aller dans ce sens parce que on est
vraiment sur des produits qui t'aident à
mieux vivre et c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
génial dans cette keynote de samsung moi
je suis piquée apple je suis pro apple
sheila monde j'ai la table elle dit tout
ce que tu veux
j'ai presque la complète mais tu vois
très bien que samsung a tout compris on
va aujourd'hui vers des objets de plus
en plus connectés kit offre plus de
liberté qui d'un autre côté temps ferme
parce que tu es enfermé dans un système
et une fois que tu es maqué avec une
marque c'est compliqué d'en sortir
une fois que tu es mac est directement
avec samsung que tu as la montre que tu
as la tablette que tu as le téléphone
coûte haldex que tu as la caméra
pourquoi tu acheté un smartphone apple
c'est strictement ridicule tous tes
sauvegardes ci dessus et tout est
produit sont dessus ça n'a strictement
aucun sens donc tout l'enjeu pour les
marques se situe là c'est être le plus
innovant innovant premier réussir à
choper le consommateur au départ à une
fac tu l'as tu crées des produits qui
s'imbriquent les uns avec les autres
tu les gardes est tueur vanter nouveaux
produits à la mode
[Musique]
c'est là
où
ma chance
donc là j'attends avec impatience
d'avoir un petit peu là les nouveautés
ce que va proposer un peul d'ici quelque
temps quand ils vont sortir leur nouvel
iphone 8 l'iphone pour les 10 ans voir
un petit peu ce qui va se profiler sur
sept pilotes et pouvoir se rendre compte
que dans quelle direction ils vont j'ose
imaginer que ils ont innové il se doute
de ce que samsung fait ils ont aussi
effectivement une boîte ils ont un
service de développement qui est là pour
se rendre compte un peu de l'innovation
et puis pouvoir anticiper le marché le
marché évolue à vitesse grand v
c'est complètement impressionnant il ya
quelques années on n'aurait pas imaginé
ça je te dis je le vois en commentaire
jeudi tous vos commentaires il ya encore
auxerre qui est intéressant je ne sais
plus qui l'a mis en marquant et pourquoi
pas d'ici quelques temps la voiture
samsung mais la réalité elle est
exactement là dans quelques temps tu
aura peut-être pas la voiture samsung
mais tu te dis tu auras au moins l'ol on
va vers tous les objets connectés il ya
des vêtements connectés il ya des
montres connecter tout le système
devient connectés pourquoi s'emmerder à
avoir je dirais plusieurs os plusieurs
sauvegardes différentes plusieurs choses
différentes
alors tu peux tout avoir alors
effectivement après dans l'absolu on
peut se demander si c'est une bonne
chose
il est toujours plus connecté quelque
part on devient dépendant le technology
puis on le voit bien
on est tous abrutis tu as vu quand
pokémon go est sorti tout le monde avait
son pokémon goto ont été connectés et à
la limite ça déshumanise un petit peu il
faut franchir un cap
je pense que quand on commence à rentrer
dans la technologie on est dans un côté
un petit peu addictif
on la découvre on est un petit peu
choqué par la technologie mais tu le
vois très bien après une fois que tu
t'es rendu compte de ce qu'a
technologique taf un petit peu le tour
tout ça tu en ressors et tulle utilisent
vraiment comme un objet et non plus
comme une fin en soi et non plus être
tout le temps connecté c'est l'objet qui
te sert donc la réelle question de
savoir est ce que je vais vers samsung
ou est-ce que je vais vers apple la
question à ce poste par rapport à
l'environnement et par rapport à ce que
proposent les marques
aujourd'hui samsung va vraiment je
dirais prend le pas des créateurs de
contenu une caméra à 360 degrés des
lunettes vr on est vraiment vers du
divertissement tu le vois le message est
clair vous créez on vous donne
les outils pour le faire c'est
exactement ça on est vers du
divertissement
on est vers des créatifs et c'est
vraiment ce qu'est en train de faire
aujourd'hui samsung
je ne demande qu'à voir ce que va faire
un peu les caisses qui vont nous
proposer lors de leur prochaine keynote
et je pense que c'est là qu'on va
vraiment se rendre compte de la
différence entre samsung et apple parce
que à un moment ou un autre il va bien
falloir qu'ils diffèrent aussi
ils peuvent pas faire des copies autant
tu me faire une copie sur un téléphone
portable des bords incurvés un grand
écran bon ça c'est l'objet principal
mais après en terme de technologie déjà
bien falloir qu'ils se différencient ça
va se faire au travers des applications
au travers de choix stratégiques choix
stratégique durable pour la boîte pour
qu'elle se démarque et qu'elle prenne le
meilleur pas le meilleur plis pour
choper le maximum de consommateurs sas à
surveiller de très près on en reparle
pendant tous ces mois et on en parlera
même après hâte de voir la prochaine qui
note toujours est il que samsung a fait
très très fort il se peut que je switche
chez samsung
si toutefois apple n'est pas à la
hauteur et n'est pas au rendez vous
s'ils nous sortent juste une énième
version de leur iphone même si c'est une
version magnifique
il faudra se poser des questions et y
aura peut-être moyen de partir chez
samsung
pour l'instant c'est pas encore le débat
on attend de voir mais je te dis c'est
un débat qui est passionnant quand on
s'intéresse à la vie future et à toutes
ces nouvelles technologies
c'est vraiment hyper passionnant dis moi
ce que t'en pense même à tout
commentaire dis moi ce que tu as pensé
de tous ses produits
regarde un petit peu ça de plus près on
en discute et puis je te dis à très
bientôt
[Musique]
m
allez
le centre
je me